dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly if I here what are
caustics a caustic is a beautiful
phenomenon in nature where curved
surfaces reflect or refract light and
thereby concentrating it to a relatively
small area it looks majestic and it is
the favorite effect of most light
transport researchers you can witness it
around rings plastic bottles or when
you're underwater just to name a few
examples if you have a powerful
algorithm at hand that can simulate many
light transport effects then you can
expect to get some caustics forming in
the presence of curved refractive or
reflective surfaces and small light
sources if you would like to know more
about caustics I am holding an entire
University course at the Technical
University of Vienna the entirety of
which we have recorded live on video for
you it is available for everyone free of
charge if you are interested check it
out as always a link is available in the
description box now the laws that lead
to caustics are well understood by
physicists therefore we can not only put
some objects on a table and just enjoy
the imagery of the caustics but we can
turn the whole thing around this
technique makes it possible to
essentially imagine any kind of caustic
pattern for instance this brain pattern
and it will create the model that will
cast caustics that look exactly like
that we can thereby design an object by
its caustics
it also works with sunlight
and you can also choose different colors
for your caustics
this result with an extremely high
fidelity image of Albert Einstein and
his signature shows that first a light
transport simulation is run and then the
final solution can be 3d printed
I am always adamantly looking for
research works where we have a
simulation that relates to and tells us
something new about the world around us
this is a beautiful example of that
you
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time